malgré les apparences le héros du film
actuellement en tournage au dessus de
saint maurice ne s'appelle pas don josé
mais monsieur jo pour l'anniversaire de
son mari auteur dramatique connu madame
brisbart comédienne interprété par
claude gensac donne une garden party son
cadeau d'anniversaire un kiosque à
musique autour duquel les invités du
couple s'assemblent pour applaudir les
attractions qui leur sont ainsi au fait
j'essaie d'arriver à l'article
invisible mais présent monsieur jour
maître chanteur ne quitte pas sa victime
monsieur brisbart que joe louis ii si
bernard billets à structure du crew
surveille étroitement ne brille pas
cette pelle a beaucoup d'importance
elle a servi à enterrer le canard oui
parce que j'ai tué quelqu'un je ne sais
pas qui j'ai tué voilà c'était soit je
suis quelqu'un je je je prends la
décision de tuer un maître chanteur qui
me demandent toujours des millions et
des millions et des millions
régulièrement chaque semaine ça ne
s'arrête pas pour une chose qu'il est
futile ma femme et mes demandes et je
lui donne ses millions et un jour je
décide de le tuer et je me documente
reprenne ami à moi qui est avocat qui me
dépasse faire une parfait mais en me
disant je vais écrire une pièce
policière cunard une pièce spéciale car
je suis auteur dramatique
et je donne rendez-vous le maître
chanteur qui vient à contre-jour jeu là
juste j'ai tout préparé tout est prêt
pour l'ensevelir tout est fait dans je
le descends je l' enveloppe dans le
rideau de douche tout est préparé jeu
comme dans le soubassement de la
gloriette de kiosques justement je le
colle la soul et c'est terminé je bâtis
meda gloriette là dessus c'est fini on
n'en parle plus et le lendemain à
l'inspecteur qui est bernard blier et
l'avenir c'est monsieur je suis
stupéfait race et c'est maintenant celui
là que j'aime chez et j'ai dit oui et il
vit vertueux on vient de trouver marché
nuit monsieur jo avec une balle dans la
tête
c'est impossible
et alors là je me demande qui je vais
fut tué assez fade mais à tous les amis
et le mord inconnu alias monsieur jo
prisonniers du ciment qui soutient la
gloriette ne laisse pas de repos à
monsieur brice barre
on dit parfois que l'emprise d'un rôle
dépasse le cadre du studio est ce
qu'elle est actuellement
vous vous sentez mal à l'aise et
coupable quand vous rencontrez alain
genre d'enlèvement pour l'ucl et on n'a
jamais la tension se fait en filtres
manière de toute manière le seul crime
dont on puisse accuser louis de funès
c'est de nous faire mourir de rire
un crime dont il refuse l'entière
responsabilité
c'est un don je crois ce que j'ai vu au
collège je n'ai pas beaucoup âgées font
rire y en a deux ou trois supposons 3
sur sambre ou deux sur 100 mais c'est ce
culte yves quand même à lui voilà comme
par exemple un jardinier on lui donne un
très bon terrain mais il faut le
cultiver je ne suis pas rien à faire
bien sûr que les bills tard et puis
longtemps paix toute la vie bien au delà
sion tv j'espère vous nous fait rire
encore longtemps mais j'espère bien le
port de cayenne nous savons nous la
preuve un extrait de ce qui a déjà été
mis en boîte avec michel galabru le
masson responsable du ciment ces
politiques regardez c'est du soleil
alors je bois à ce bel édifice
et puis à ce qu'ils soient là qu'est ce
qui est sûr c'est que rien de ce que
j'ai ainsi il n'y a rien de souci il ya
le sol de la france hariri alors vive la
france vive